[Musique]
bonsoir à tous mardi 18 septembre
bienvenue dans le 7-8 journal de tv 78
tout de suite les titres de cette
édition
ce groupe est implanté à saint quentin
en yvelines depuis près de 40 ans
socotec a inauguré hier son nouveau
siège à guyancourt en présence de
plusieurs élus locaux un site de 7000 m²
qui accueille 450 salariés
anciennement basé à guyancourt et
montigny le bretonneux elle nous étions
sur place
un français sur cinq ne mange pas à sa
faim enseignement dans un dernier
sondage ipsos pour le secours populaire
une précarité qui progresse dans le
département alors qu emmanuel macron a
annoncé récemment son implant pauvreté
invité de ce journal pascal rodier
secrétaire général du secours populaire
des yvelines et puis dans tout juste une
semaine la ryder cup débutera à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines nous
continuons de vous présenter le parcours
de la compétition
focus également à suivre sur l'héritage
que pourrait aller c'est l'événement au
territoire
et puis nous nous interrogerons
également dans ce journal sur les
conséquences locales de cette annonce la
suppression prochaine de 1600 postes au
ministère des sports avec notre invité
luc miserait est la police de sécurité
du quotidien entre dans le concret
aujourd'hui dans 15 quartiers
prioritaires le ministre de l'intérieur
gérard collomb l'a annoncé hier lors
d'une visite à corbeil essonnes qui fait
partie du dispositif
tout comme la commune de trappes d'après
le ministère les premiers effectifs ont
pris leurs fonctions aujourd'hui dans le
quartier des merisiers et de la plaine 2
nov
elle la police de sécurité du quotidien
prévoit notamment de 15 à 30 renfort aux
effectifs des gens en place et une
proximité renforcée avec la population
l'une des priorités la lutte contre le
trafic de stupéfiants
un nouveau siège pour socotec cette
entreprise de contrôle dans le secteur
de la construction les inauguré hier à
lundi à guyancourt une nouvelle
installation qui intègre et les trois
anciens sites déjà installés dans
l'agglomération saint-quentinoise lé
détail avec nicolas landry c'est une
entreprise historique de saint quentin
en yvelines le groupe socotec a inauguré
son nouveau siège à guyancourt
installé depuis 1900
119 sur l'agglomération elle a regroupé
ses trois sites et ses 450 salariés sur
un espace de 7000 m² avec un attachement
certain au territoire
alors ce nouveau siège qui représente
d'abord un environnement de travail
radicalement nouveau pour les 450
collaborateurs qui travaillent ici
beaucoup plus ouvert beaucoup plus enfin
facilitant le travail en transversal
exprimant beaucoup mieux ce que doit
être un environnement de travail
aujourd'hui en 2018 présent lors de
cette inauguration jean michel fourgous
président de saint quentin en yvelines
et marie-christine le tarnec maire de
guyancourt travailler main dans la main
avec les entreprises saint-quentinoise
la volonté des élus vous savez 50 1 c
c'est en fait que j'ai toujours c'est un
trip le pôle d'excellence excellence
sportive ya qu à voir aujourd'hui dans
quelques journaux la ryder cup c'est un
pôle d'excellence économique la qualité
des entreprises à 50 n est plus à
démontrer dans l allée assez
extraordinaire et puis aussi un pôle
scientifique avec également l'arrivée de
paris saclay lapointe universités
françaises qui va être le le pôle
scientifique et technologique delà de la
france des entreprises sur une collecte
pour une collectivité c'est très
important au niveau des budgets avec la
baisse de notation effectivement de
l'état ça nous permet d'avoir des
financements importants pour mettre du
service public à disposition des
habitants
socotec réalise aujourd'hui près de 700
millions d'euros de chiffre d'affaires
spécialisée dans les tests l'inspection
et la certification dans le domaine de
la construction et des infrastructures
avec ce nouveau site le groupe a pour
ambition de devenir le leader européen
du secteur une stratégie nationale
dévoilée le 13 septembre dernier
emmanuel macron annoncé son plan pour
endiguer la pauvreté plusieurs mesures
chiffrées à 8,5 milliards d'euros sur
quatre ans notamment renforcer lé
dispositif d'accompagnement de retour à
l'emploi instaurer un revenu universel
d'activité mais aussi des actions en
faveur de la jeunesse et de la petite
enfance mettre en place par exemple des
petits déjeuners pour les écoliers des
zones prioritaires ce plan pauvreté
intervient dans un contexte de
progression de la précarité en france et
dans les yvelines
c'est sur cinq elle ne mange pas à sa
faim d'après un dernier sondage ipsos
pour le secours populaire français
bonsoir pascal rodier en soit vous êtes
le secrétaire général du secours
populaire des yvelines en septembre
votre association est en pleine campagne
pauvreté précarité on en parle juste
après la pauvreté progresse en france
est ce que c'est le même constat que
vous dressez dans les yvelines
oui mon avis les les yvelines n'échappe
pas au constat national et ce qui nous
inquiète c'est qu'en fait c'est les gens
qui sont de plus en plus pauvres en plus
c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui il est
urgent d'agir il ya le ce plan au niveau
politique annoncée par ligne emmanuel
macron c'est aussi pour les associations
de continuer le travail qu'elles
qu'elles font sur le terrain il ya ça et
puis la difficulté c'est qu'en fait y
compris pour des associations de
caractère généraliste comme le secours
populaire en fait de plus en plus les
gens nous sollicitent pour un petit peu
tout dans le quotidien et donc ça
complexifie d'autant plus la tâche des
bénévoles en fait sur le terrain on aura
l'occasion de parler de l'ensemble de
vos actions alors d'après le sondage
plus de 8 millions de français vivent
aujourd'hui sous le seuil de pauvreté
qui est fixé à 1000 15 euros et une
précarité
c'est le sondage qui le met en avant qui
est avant tout alimentaire aujourd'hui
c'est les français ont du mal à se
nourrir
voilà c'est assez dramatique en fait de
se dire qu'au xxième siècle il ya quand
même un compatriote sur cinq qui est qui
réussit pas à s'alimenter correctement
et puis
ça fait partie des besoins vitaux quand
même donc c'est préoccupant que les
besoins vitaux ne puisse être satisfait
correctement pour une partie de nos
compatriotes qui ont des difficultés à
se nourrir et aussi à se nourrir
convenablement beaucoup disent avoir des
difficultés à acheter des fruits frère à
consommer du poisson api aussi la
cantine des enfants c'est aussi une
difficulté oui à se nourrir
convenablement c'est ça et puis la
fameuse règle d'un légume cinq fruits et
légumes par jour est inaccessible pour
des visions des millions de français
manger de la viande rouge une fois par
semaine n'est pas possible pour ces
personnes là donc j'ai pas aussi vous
rendez coupe quand on voit des chiffres
comme ça c'est quand même assez effarant
quoi puisque on pourrait s'imaginer
quand même que étant dans un pays riche
ce soit plus ce type de problèmes
auxquels on peut être confrontés quoi
est ce que d'ailleurs les personnes
divines hausse qui viennent vous voir au
secours populaire désigne c'est avant
tout pour cette aide alimentaire
bah oui alors il ya aussi le fait qu'on
est identifiée comme une association et
des panneaux au niveau alimentaire et
puis comme je disais c'est un besoin
vital donc un quand c'est vital on a un
petit peu moins de scrupules aussi à
pousser la porte quand on quand on va
pas bien et donc pour nous c'est aussi
une porte d'entrée c'est à dire qu'on le
conçoit comme ça sert que l'aide
alimentaire c'est le la chose naturelle
et puis ça permet quand on établit le
contact avec la personne de lui proposer
d'autres formes de solidarité peut être
un petit peu plus sur le temps long et
qu'ils puissent lui permettent de
trouver des issues ou des solutions
quand c'est possible pour sortir de la
précarité
d'autres réactions qu'on va développer
dans un instant combien de familles ont
bénéficié de l'aide alimentaire du
secours populaire dans les yvelines plus
de 1700 familles sont inscrites
régulièrement en fait
au niveau de l'aide alimentaire et puis
après il peut y avoir des dépannages
d'urgence difficulté sur l'alimentation
et aussi un grand nombre de sondés qui
parle de difficultés à payer certains
frais médicaux qui sont mal remboursés
par la sécurité sociale 38% et même
certains estiment avoir du mal à
disposer d'une mutuelle santé ça veut
dire qu'aujourd'hui on a des difficultés
à s'alimenter il y aussi des difficultés
à bien soigner en france
oui parce que en fait il ya des
mécanismes qui font que la santé de
moins en moins accessible aussi il ya un
transfert de charges vers les mutuelles
dans un sens être trop technique je
pense que les personnes qui regardent
comprennent maintenant si vous n'avez
pas de mutuelle il ya toute une partie
de vos soins qui sont peu ou pas du tout
remboursés et donc qui dit accès à la
mutuelle du paiement de la mutuelle qui
dit paiement de la mutuelle dit capacité
à le faire et pour les personnes en
situation tendue
c'est compliqué et souvent on nous
oppose la cmu la cmu c'est donc ce sont
des mécanismes couverture maladie
universelle et complémentaires pour les
plus précaires mais il ya toutes les
personnes qui se situe au delà de ces
plafonds là pour qui il n'y a pas de
possibilité d'accès à prix réduit et
donc ça rend les soins de base compliqué
il ya beaucoup de personnes qui
renoncent à des soins de santé basiques
par manque de moyens le dentaire
notamment c'est une réelle problématique
le secours populaire notamment qui aide
les familles en équipement lunettes
oui il ya d'autres actions alors on le
disait tout à l'heure cette campagne
pauvreté précarité avec de multiples
initiatives c'est pas que l'aide
alimentaire c'est beaucoup plus d'action
sur un panel large on peut dire envoyer
comme on dit souvent dans notre
association le l'être humain n'est pas
qu'un estomac sur pattes c'est un peu
triviale mais tout le monde comprend
c'est à dire que en fait c'est le besoin
alimentaire c'est se nourrir et boire de
l'eau ça c'est indispensable à la vie et
mais en fait il ya la culture l'estiment
deux soirs on la santé on l'a dit
l'accès au droit aussi il ya un besoin
de plus en plus d'informations ce qu'une
multiplication mécanismes qui rendent
difficile y compris pour les
professionnels du champ social de
connaître tous les tous les mécanismes
donc du coup la lutte contre la pauvreté
la précarité c'est bien plus que
soutenir au niveau matériel
les personnes c'est aussi un devoir on
va dire de citoyenneté c'est à dire
n'aime pas laisser enfin laisser le
moins possible de personnes sur le sur
le bas-côté quoi et d'autres actions n'a
pas le temps de les développer puisque
on arrive à la fin de cet entretien mais
notamment sur l'aide au départ en
vacances il ya eu un village copains du
monde qui s'est tenue c'est l'une des
actions qui était cet été à lille de
loisirs de saint quentin en yvelines
merci parce qu'elle revient d'abord est
avec toi c'est moi qui vous remercie je
rappelle que vous êtes le secrétaire
général du secours populaire des
yvelines
[Musique]
une initiative citoyenne mondiale samedi
c'était le world cleanup des 130 pays se
sont mobilisés pour nettoyer la planète
à plaisir une quarantaine de personnes
s'est réunie à l'initiative d'une
association locale reportage de marie
lehn iapichino et michael et demi
d'euros une bataille de pince pour
ramasser un mégot de cigarette
pas de doute les enfants se sont pris au
jeu du ramassage de déchets une façon
ludique pour ce père de famille de
sensibiliser ses enfants de 8 et 12 ans
son respect de l'environnement
tu vois là le papier là ça aussi ça fait
partie des choses qu'on ramasse des
packs dans l'herbe en fait c'est la
ville dans sa globalité
et puis qu'ils objets du quotidien
retrouver dans la nature ton temps
particulièrement présente une petite
chose parce que tu as vu en les
cigarettes sans fin entre gros de la
pollution pour l'instant au bilan de
voir tout ce qui est je t'ai je pense
que ça va aussi les 106 vis-à-vis de
leurs copains et peut-être les amener à
à dire leurs copains de quoi jeter par
terre plaisir en transition a pensé à
tout pour permettre la récolte au mieux
sans oublier le tri des déchets la
chariotte elle permet de délester un peu
les personnes qui ramasse et de faire du
tri bas directement c'est à dire le vert
le carton et les ordures ménagères de
manière un peu plus facile
sensibilisation réussi chez les plus
jeunes qui se confronte directement à la
quantité de déchets retrouvés hors des
poubelles le nom de déféquer à par terre
et les noms de cigarettes
c'est plutôt énorme déjà devant chez moi
y'en a plein du coup ça ça commence à
m'énerver un peu oui je sensible et sa
manière vraiment les airs en transition
renouvellera l'action régulièrement
prochain rendez vous dans les rues de la
commune
fin octobre une information révélée
début septembre dans une lettre de
cadrage matignon souhaite supprimer 1600
postes de conseiller technique au
ministère des sports c'est d'ici à 2022
le budget des sports sera par ailleurs
amputé de 30 millions d'euros dès l'an
prochain bonsoir le cnis dresse en soir
vous êtes conseiller sportif à la
direction départementale de la cohésion
sociale également syndicaliste snep fsu
on va voir avec vous quelles
conséquences locales pourraient avoir
cette décision d'abord une réaction
assez prochaine suppression est ce que
c'est un mauvais signal envoyé par le
gouvernement on est à quelques années
des jeux olympiques à paris de 2024
c'est un très mauvais signal pour les
jeux olympiques et paralympiques
c'est également un très mauvais signal
pour le développement du sport dans
notre pays
ce qu'il faut bien comprendre c'est que
il ya deux catégories un petit peu chez
nous il ya ce qu'on a entendu les cts
conseiller technique et sportif qui sont
des personnels qui sont mis à
disposition par l'état auprès des
fédérations qui après les décline il ya
des entraîneurs nationaux il y à des
cadres au niveau régional ou au niveau
départemental et puis nous qui sommes en
l'occurrence moi j'ai fait les deux mais
nous qui sommes des conseillers sportifs
au sein des directions régionales
départementales et au sein des
directions départementales ce qui est
très important dans le cas de la
proximité c'est à dire de
l'accompagnement qu'on peut apporter aux
associations pourquoi le statut de cadre
d'état est important et de
fonctionnaires d'état pourquoi on a mis
des fonctionnaires d'état pour une bonne
et simple raison c'était de les rendre
indépendants par rapport à tout groupe
de pression ou tout lobby etc
c'est ça l'objet et c'est ça que ce
gouvernement est en l'occurrence le
président de la république veut détruire
et ça c'est extrêmement grave
alors c'est grave parce que les
fédérations par exemple il y avait eu
une lettre je sais pas si vous avez vu
monsieur rouge et le président de la
fédération française de judo qui disait
il ya quelques années on nous a proposé
des postes de cadres on nous a dit on
les supprime
en tant que fonctionnaire d'état ce qui
prouve bien que l'idée est dans les
têtes depuis hier un certain temps et
puis on vous compensera financièrement
la première année ils ont touché 100 %
pas de problème
la deuxième année ils ont touché 50 % et
la troisième année ils ont touché 25 %
et après ils ont pu rien toucher du tout
dix essais post dont on parle au
ministère des sports il concerne
notamment la direction les directions
départementales de la jeunesse des
sports et de la cohésion sociale ça veut
dire qu'aujourd'hui votre service
votre post se retrouve directement
menacés alors aujourd'hui on soit vous
avez eu des retours pour l'instant on
sait pas grand chose mais ce qu'on sait
c'est que donc pour les cadres qui sont
auprès des fédérations
le risque c'est aussi que ceux qui sont
dans des fédérations qui ont plus de
moyens parce que plus médiatisé s'en
sortiront plus ou moins bien mais y
laisseront des plumes
quant aux autres alors là ça va être
compliqué et donc c'est tout le modèle
puisqu'on prend comme référence le les
jeux olympiques et paralympiques qu'on
nous présente par rapport au système
anglais on dit à londres ils ont créé
une agence
ils ont eu plein de médailles c'est très
bien sauf que dans le même temps ce
qu'on nous dit pas c'est que il ya eu
une chute considérable du nombre de
licenciés en angleterre parce que
l'argent est uniquement concentré sur
les disciplines qui pouvait rapporter
des médailles les autres elles ont été
complètement délaissé et alors le
développement du sport dans son ensemble
lui il s est il est laissé pour compte
donc ces décisions sont extrêmement
graves et les associations puisque vous
me posez la question quelle résonance ça
va avoir
oui c'est ça c'est des fédérations on
imagine qu'au niveau local aussi ça
pourrait avoir des incidences
voilà par exemple
je vous cite trois exemples en date nous
on a travaillé au sein de la ddcs des
yvelines pour accompagner les comités
départementaux sur la diversification
des ressources financières
au départ on l'a fait sur l'optique du
développement associatif et du
développement du sport nous est arrivé
là dessus toutes les mauvaises annonces
gouvernementales de réduction drastique
faut quand même s'imaginer c'est 50% du
cns en moins en une année c'est ce et
c'est c'est énorme
donc du coup voilà on a mis en place une
une académie des entraîneurs sportifs
pour qu'ils se rencontrent pour qu'ils
échangent de leurs compétences on il ya
des richesses énormes
sauf qu'elles sont maintenus en sommeil
sa folle dynamiser qu'il fait les
fédérations si elle le faisait ça
faisait longtemps qu'elle l'aurait fait
donc si nous on n'avait pas été là pour
le faire voilà troisième exemple qui est
celui sur lequel on travaille à l'heure
actuelle ces deux d'accompagner les
associations à tous les niveaux sur on
dit souvent faut repenser le modèle
économique associatif et ben on les
accompagne là dessus on les accompagne
sur les ressources qui sont les leurs
qui fait ça leur fédération ne le font
pas donc il ya cette complémentarité qui
nous permet de faire ça et c'est ça que
le gouvernement veut supprimer beaucoup
de risques on l'a compris il est apte à
son arrivée déjà la fin de cet entretien
est une mobilisation est prévue est ce
que vous allez répondre à ces à ces
annonces alors il ya des mobilisations
qui sont en cours donc au niveau des
conseillers qui sont touchées mais nous
on est un tout petit ministère pourquoi
ils sont attaqués à nohant premier faux
pas que les gens se leurre on s'attaque
à nous en premier les autres vont suivre
1 donc on a intérêt à tous se réunir
dans ce combat là pour sauver le service
public parce que l'état est le garant de
l'éthique républicaine
c'est à dire de l'équité de tous les
français de toutes les associations quel
que soit leur choix leur discipline leur
territoire et bien c'est cette équité là
qui remise en cause
merci elle utiliserait d'avoir répondu à
nos questions je rappelle que vous êtes
conseiller sportif à la direction
départementale de la cohésion sociale
syndicalistes pour la snep fsu
merci d'avoir été avec nous gimont 7
avant le début de la ryder cup à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines la compétition
n'a pas encore commencé mais déjà c'est
l'heure de voir quel héritage elle
pourrait laisser au territoire une
conférence débat sur le sujet était
organisée la semaine dernière et michele
l'hydro dépassé le chiffre des 410 mille
golfeurs licenciés c'est l'objectif
clairement affiché par la fédération
française avec l'organisation de la
première ryder cup sur le territoire
français la structure espère bénéficier
de ce coup de projecteur planétaire pour
attirer de nouveaux adeptes
on pense qu'après cette ryder cup
évidemment un plus grand nombre de
personnes auront
eu un premier contact avec le golf et on
espère que bien sûr ils vont se mettre à
jouer au golf pour créer une nouvelle
génération de passionnés la fédération
française à parier sur la jeunesse en
lançant dès 2015 à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines mon carnet de
golf sur la ryder cup leur programme
éducatif ludique pour les cm1 et cm2 le
succès qu'a remporté 7 cette opération a
poussé l'éducation nationale à étendre
l'opération sur tout le territoire
donc oui ça marche et ça continue à
marcher et ça va encore marcher la ryder
cup 2018 va également permettre au golf
national de saint-quentin-en-yvelines de
se faire un nom avec sa rénovation à 7,5
millions d'euros l'albatros est
considéré comme l'un des meilleurs
parcours au monde un standing qui lui
permettra d'organiser de nouvelles
compétitions internationales dans le
futur nous voulons poursuivre cette
politique d'accueil de grands événements
pour montrer et concrétiser toujours ce
savoir faire français et que la ryder
cup nous a offert et pourquoi pas je ne
dis pas que nous ferons mais on pourra y
tenir
après la ryder cup à accueillir la salle
polyvalent féminin en attendant la
solheim cup le golf national accueillera
en 2022 les championnats du monde et en
2024 les jeux olympiques
le golf à saint quentin en yvelines une
histoire d'amour qui devrait durer et
toute cette semaine nous vous présentons
le parcours de cette ryder cup 2018
place au trou numéro deux secteurs
compliqué pour les joueurs
patrick jacques de dixmude et mickaël
landreau
m
bienvenue sur le trou numéro 2 donc trop
numéro 2 qui va
mais plein de coups à ses stratégies
également à jouer pour pour l'épauler
joueurs la ryder cup pourquoi parce que
c'est un trou qui techniquement est
assez compliqué c'était un trou sur
lequel si le joueur a mal engagé le
produit méreau un peu ce vide se mettre
la pression sur ce trou numéro 2 6
langage mal ce trou numéro 2 peut vite
se mettre la pression pour la suite la
suite du tournoi un numéro deux qui
étaient en par trois qui fait sens
en 92 mètres de 110 yards avec qu'on
pouvait voir la plus grosse des
difficultés qui est à
abello l'obstacle d'eau qui heureusement
on va dire plus le présentent eux devant
le green et surtout face aux green qui a
encore une fois un peu similaire à ce
trou numéro un est un green qui est
plutôt dans la largeur est assez peu
dans la profondeur donc là vraiment la
difficulté ça sera la foule
encore une fois qui sera certainement
assez nombreuse autour de ceux de ce
trou là parce que là la priorité c'est
de trouver et de faire le bon choix du
club parce que il faut quand même posé
une balle avec énormément de pression à
plus de 190 m
avec la punition qui est immédiate si le
coup est mal touché où le club trop
court même trop long parce que quand on
peut le voir au fond derrière il ya
quand même dur est fait des bunkers qui
accueilleront les balles avec grand
plaisir
[Musique]
donc là on est sur le green du trou
numéro 2 donc ça va contre quoi c'est
spectaculaire parce que ça reste du
match play et donc le match fut leurs
différentes stratégies soient les
joueurs qui vont être beaucoup dans
l'offensive qui vont attaquer tous les
bas soit plus tôt on va dire dans une
stratégie plutôt d'attentes mais il
n'empêche que le drapeau au fond à
gauche sera prêt délicat et l'autre
position également qui est extrêmement
délicate
c'est à l'entrée à droite parce que là
vraiment la zone sur laquelle le joueur
peut poser la balle est vraiment je sais
pas et d'ailleurs à peu près 3 4 mètres
de profondeur et si il est en dehors
serre que s'il a un pourra jouer du
vainqueur un coup à jouer du rock ou si
le courrier est mal touché avec une
balle trop courte mais tout de suite le
joueur est délicat donc trou numéro 2 on
est toujours dans l'arène de l'est pas
et je pense que sur ces deux trous qu'on
a vu trop de numéros un trou numéro deux
il me va se passer beaucoup de choses à
la fin du mois et du golf national nous
allons au vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines est l'écrin
accueilli ce week-end le vélodrome sport
ce day avec une nouveauté sur place la
glisse urbaine elle les objectifs de
l'événement au micro de michael et demi
d'euros faire découvrir en fait des
nouvelles activités en plus de celles
qu'on a inauguré en 2014 et notamment
celles que j'ai introduit précédemment
là les sports de glisse urbaine
notamment les circuits dover board
on avait aussi la partie trampoline là
on est mal en sports de glisse mais
c'est des choses qu'on proposait pas
auparavant et qui aujourd'hui nous
permettre de compléter notre panel
d'activités
l'idée c'était de repérer ce qui allait
plaire le plus à faire les statistiques
de fréquentation les inscriptions et
puis ensuite à travers cela pourquoi pas
inaugurer une école de sport lors de la
rentrée prochaine à travers les foires
qui ont
fonctionné aujourd'hui on termine ce
journal avec le coup de coeur culture du
mardi bonsoir mélanie pauli votre coup
de coeur cette semaine et musical on se
rend dans un festival avec vous mais là
nous est tout à fait grégory on verra au
festival de saint germain en laye alors
ça se passe du 21 septembre au 6 octobre
et ce ne sont pas moins de 33 artistes
qui répondent présents il ya bénabar
christophe laurent voulzy noah nolwenn
leroy bien sûr c'est dur de citer tout
le monde vers le festival a peut-être
plus de 30 ans mais cette année c'est
aussi un anniversaire c'est celui des
vitrines découvertes ont fait découvrir
des jeunes vers pipe bénabar et d'autres
sont passés par l'équivalent dans les
découvertes et donc là cette année mais
ce sont les 10 ans des vitrines
découverte dans leur formule nationale
et internationale puisque on fera
découvrir le 22 septembre après midi
cet artiste qui viennent de belgique du
canada de suisse et de france
on a vu mélanie les visages de ces sept
artistes francophones en écoutant le
directeur de l'estival qui sont ils ces
artistes alors il ya trois représentants
français alice qui a sorti son premier
ep en 2017
on a aussi beauty and the beast qui joue
la carte old school en mêlant du blues
du folk du swing ou encore john milo
alors nos voisins suisses et belges sont
représentés par les fils du facteur et
yvan tirtiaux et les deux derniers ont
traversé l'atlantique
émile bilodeau et chandails pelouse
viennent du canada 33 artistes ou
groupes difficile de faire son choix
parmi cette offre comme et la nièce que
vous nous ont conseillés un ou une
alors moi j'ai plutôt me fier aux
directeurs du festival parce qu'il m'a
cité un artiste à plusieurs reprises
lors de notre entretien
et il s'agit de loïc lantoine il sera
accompagné du very big expirant
expérimental to be free orchestra c'est
une association qui est né d'une
rencontre entre un poète à la voix
rocailleuse et un orchestre de 18
musiciens écouter
je pourrais très très vite après le
premier cheveu blanc la plus belle
quand tout à coup et j'ai retourné la
première fois que je les ai vues elles
étaient grands
la deuxième fois que je les vois
et d'immenses
tuez pas fouillé que chez moi
tête à prince
et si je t'aurais moi qui tremble
je danse comme
je pense quand même je danse dans même
jeu tant ils se produiront le 22
septembre au théâtre du vésinet
l'estival hui débute le 21 septembre
avec un concert gratuit d'amélie de
catherine lara et cette 31e édition est
aussi dédié à l'association autour des
williams qui sauva grégory contre une
maladie génétique le syndrome de
williams et ben belle initiative merci
mélanie pour cette chronique on vous
retrouve dans un instant avec un nouveau
numéro de votre émission le 7-8 culture
c'est la fin de cette édition le 7-8
journal et bien sûr à revoir sur notre
site internet et notre application
mobile très bonne soirée avec tv 78
[Musique]